vous savez le 49-3 ce que je veux
rappeler ici sur ce plateau ce soir et
devant nos concitoyens qui nous écoutent
c'est que c'est un outil qui est
constitutionnel alors justement c'est la
deuxième question qu'on va se poser
parce que c'est vraiment
anti-constitutionnel est-ce que c'est
anti-démocratique la deuxième question
va se poser c'est encore une fois c'est
un autre débat mais on a activé le 49-3
parce que le Président de la République
parce que ça première ministre parce que
le gouvernement a estimé que cette
réforme des retraites était nécessaire
parce que nous avons allons nous allons
avoir un système des retraites qui sera
déficitaire dans quelques années et face
à cela on a un président de la
République qui a fait campagne avec une
promesse moi je vais vous donner mon
sentiment et le sentiment que je
je sens un petit peu en parlant avec
énormément de français est-ce que le
timing était le bon déjà il va sur il y
a un problème voilà avec cette réforme
mais aussi le timing on sait qu'en ce
moment
l'inflation est très très importante on
parle tous de d'un Marceau rouge voilà
et qu'aujourd'hui les Français ils ont
du mal à aller faire parcours ça a mangé
alors fin à donner à manger à leurs
enfants il y a même des parents qui
viennent ici sur le plateau qui disent
voilà nous on peut pas manger parce
qu'on on veut nourrir nos enfants et
qu'on aime on travaille tous les deux de
8h du matin à 19h et on arrive pas à les
nourrir donc il y a ce problème là il y
a le problème de l'Ukraine il y a le
problème c'est central nucléaire il y a
le problème de l'électricité donc il y a
énormément de problèmes cumulés est-ce
que c'est il fallait pas peut-être
laisser passer un petit peu tout ça et
peut-être voilà essayer de revenir après
mais là est-ce que ça met pas de
l'attention sur de l'attention mais vous
savez il y a jamais de bon moment pour
engager une réforme
il y a jamais de bons moments et je
crois que je ne suis pas le président de
la République nous ne sommes pas ici
collectivement le président de la
République et le gouvernement pour
décider quel est le domaine pour entamer
une réforme ce que je veux dire
et vous avez tout à fait raison on peut
donner notre avis en Revan vous pensez
vraiment qu'on voit ce qu'il y a dans la
rue quand on a mais vous savez
maintenant on est au responsabilités il
faut savoir faire de courage
d'anticipation et de flexibilité
sur les parents qui a pas laissez-moi
finir le texte que nous avons mais
laissez-moi au moins vous expliquer le
cheminement notre pensée le président de
la République quand il s'est présenté
pour sa réélection au mois de mai
dernier ou en avril dernier il a proposé
noir sur blanc et c'était inscrit noir
sur blanc cette réforme là des retraites
avec je le rappelle un âge légal de
départ à la retraite à 65 ans nous avons
mené des concertations avec les
présidents des groupes politiques avec
les syndicats sous l'égide de notre
ministre du Travail Olivier du soft pour
justement essayer d'assouplir ce texte
le texte qui a été débattu pendant 175
heures je le rappelle au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale qui était qui est
passé en première lecture à l'Assemblée
nationale qui a été votée au Sénat et le
fruit d'un compromis et le fruit d'un
compromis qui tient compte des
sensibilités politiques de tous les
partis politiques de notre gouvernement
on ne joue pas avec les finances
publiques de notre gouvernement nous
avons encore une fois si vous souhaitez
protéger la retraite de vos enfants
madame dans quelques années nous devons
penser dès à présent à protéger ce
système de retraite par répartition qui
sera encore une fois je le rappelle et
juste déficitaire
la retraite de ses enfants et que tout
le monde veut protéger la retraite de
ses enfants ici et voilà mais je pense
sincèrement qu'en ce moment à l'instant
t il y a des problèmes beaucoup plus
urgent à régler que la réforme des
retraites excusez-moi de vous dire ça je
suis désolé
on parle d'un truc qui va arriver non
mais je suis désolé Shannon là en ce
moment il y a une urgence pour que les
gens puissent manger à leur faim et
puissent terminer leur moi et puis se
vivre plus habiter un logement digne
donc absolument raison
parce que vu ce se passe et actuellement
dans les rues je pense que justement là
on pêche l'autre ok qu'est-ce que vous
voulez dire moi je suis j'ai le
sentiment on va pas revenir sur le fond
de la réforme parce que 80% des Français
sont comptes ils ont raison d'être
compte mais juge je trouve qu'il y a un
truc très malsain dans la politique du
gouvernement c'est-à-dire que là on est
dans une situation où les gens
commencent l'année avec un carburant à 2
€ avec une hausse des tarifs de
l'électricité des artisans boulangers là
en ce moment même qui connaissent des
fight en cascade parce que leur facture
a été multipliée par 3 4 5 6 7 8
2/3 des Français qui disent dans toutes
les enquêtes on ne mange plus à notre
faim parce qu'on a plus suffisamment
d'argent et que l'alimentation est trop
haut et on a un gouvernement qui passe
en force sur une réforme que personne ne
veut et qui passe en force je veux dire
ce qu'a fait madame bande c'est un bras
d'honneur au peuple français et à la
représentation nationale elle arrive
avec un texte de loi que madame
je pense qu'il y a rien je veux dire je
pense qu'il y a rien de courageux à dire
à une caissière ce qui a un artisan
boulanger un électricien à un maçon vous
allez travailler jusqu'à 64 ans parce
qu'on sait très bien ce qui va se passer
il y a beaucoup de gens qui sont usés
par des métiers de plus en plus pénibles
et qui partiront avant de 64 ans et qui
partiront avec une déconne le but cette
réforme c'est de faire des économies sur
sur les pensions Jordan Bardella je vais
vous dire le problème qu'on a c'est
qu'aujourd'hui des maçons de 40 ans ou 5
ans il pense même pas travailler
jusqu'au 64 ans il pense déjà si ils
vont avoir du travail dans un mois parce
qu'avec ce qui se passe actuellement je
vous dis c'est là où on va je vous dis
des gens même qui gagne assez bien leur
vie qui sont deux à travailler dans leur
foyer dans un foyer et avec
l'électricité avec l'inflation avec une
notion pas il est extrêmement malsain
parce qu'on a le sentiment qu'Emmanuel
Macron prend plaisir à avoir sa chance
il a fait ça pendant toute la crise des
gilets jaunes vous pouvez pas être
première ministre avoir un un texte en
disant écoutez la majorité les députés
de l'Assemblée qui sont censés voter la
loi ne veulent pas de ce texte les
Français ne veulent pas de ce texte les
syndicats ne veulent pas de ce texte les
partis politiques ne veulent pas de ce
texte et vous venez avec votre texte loi
dire vous allez
se fout des gens je pense qu'ils se
foutent des Français et en vérité il ne
voit pas un peuple français il voit une
population alors quand on parle de
retraite il parle pas de la vie des gens
ils parlent de statistiques et je
comptabiliser et c'est là la grande
différence entre le fossé qui est en
train de se créer entre le peuple
c'est-à-dire celui sur qui s'exerce le
pouvoir et des gens au pouvoir qui sont
complètement déconnectés dans un instant
je voudrais parler à avec Ricci Richie
Thibault vous êtes un manifestant que là
vous avez quel âge as-tu 18 ans 18 ans
d'abord dire que parce que vous êtes
politisés non mais enfin je sais pas ce
que tu veux ce que vous insinuez pas
mais juste pour dire que c'est toujours
aussi relou d'écouter des politocards il
faut passer il faut pas s'étonner que
les jeunes ne vont pas voter quand on
est ces deux personnes mais après mais
juste sur le sur l'essentiel du sujet
c'est très important sur cette réforme
des retraites l'utilisation du 49-3 pour
moi elle est très révélatrice et ça ne
m'étonne pas du tout parce que votre
gouvernement madame parce que Monsieur
Macron quand il est minoritaire il est
ultra minoritaire la seule chose qu'il
sait faire c'est utiliser la brut la
violence les gens n'acceptent pas de se
faire condamner à se casser à se faire
casser le dos deux ans au travail parce
qu'à 50 ans et je vous parle de la vie
de mon oncle de ma gueule celle de ma
grand-mère de ma grand-mère dès ils en
peuvent plus ils ont déjà les corps usés
et vous vous allez leur dire vous allez
au culot madame de leur dire qu'il faut
qu'ils travaillent jusqu'à 64 ans mais
vous êtes insolent ce que vous êtes
violentes comme Monsieur Macron et mon
appel et je lance son album
solennellement ce soir j'en ai pour 30
secondes c'est d'appeler tous les
Français toutes les Françaises à
descendre devant leur préfecture devant
leur mairie ce soir même place de la
Concorde en face de l'Assemblée
nationale parce que face à des
politiciens qui nous mettent à genoux
qui se foutent de vos gueules aux gens
qui sont autour du plateau là qui se
fout de nos vies qui ont plus d'intérêt
pour l'argent que pour la vie des gens
et bien il faut se bouger il faut se
faire entendre faut se révolter faut
plus accepter de se faire marcher dessus
il faut être debout faut s'inscrire dans
l'héritage des révolutionnaires des
communards des maquisards de toutes
celles et ceux qui rencontrent à la
violence
l'autodéfense populaire
une dernière chose politique
mes parents n'ont jamais voté n'ont
jamais fait de politique n'ont jamais
été syndiqué à 4
vous me laissez terminer à 14
à 14 ans je vais sur un rond-point je
vois des gens qui ont rien à bouffer
comme mais comme ma grand-mère qui a
galéré à l'âge de 80 ans et je me dis
Ricci toi parce que tu viens d'une
famille de gitans et ces gens qui sont
pas censés faire de la politique et bien
c'est de la politique défense et jambes
qu'on traite comme de la comme de la
merde défend les moi ce que je dis quand
tu donnes un exemple comme ça je préfère
chose terminée c'est très clair moi je
suis très gêné d'être à côté de ce type
qui fait partie d'un parti politique non
mais je termine qui fait partie non mais
qui fait partie de politique qui a
enfermé mes ancêtres vous faites partie
d'un parti politique qui est enfermé mes
ancêtres c'est pas le débat moi c'est
pas le débat juste riche
juste un truc
on essaie de représenter tous les
courants forcément tu sais c'est comme
ça qu'est-ce qu'il a dit attendez juste
il a dit vous inquiétez pas on
s'occupera de votre côté le fascisme est
une menace ça éradiquer les racines
une dernière chose non mais une dernière
chance c'est pas de d'appel à la Zurich
non une dernière chose non non une
dernière chose simplement
ce sont vos comportements jeunes qui
empêchent nos jeunes de prendre place et
de prendre en compte
votre président chéri donc moi
moi
stop stop stop moi j'entends ces
revendications mais je ne demande qu'une
chose c'est de pouvoir avoir derrière
cela un droit de réponse écoutez ces
revendications exposé face à cela nos
propositions et avancer comment est-ce
que vous voulez qu'on avance dans ce
collectionner
je termine juste sur ce point elle est
terminée l'obstruction parlementaire à
laquelle on a assisté au sein de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
c'est exactement les scènes de chaos
auxquelles on est en train d'assister
aujourd'hui dans la rue et
malheureusement on pourra pas avancer
comme ça nous sommes prêts à dialoguer
nous sommes prêts à faire des que vous
avez mal quand
voilà Carla balade des difficultés comme
la plupart des Français c'est le moment
seul qui est dans une situation précaire
car là vous faites quoi dans la vie je
suis sérieuse d'accord vous êtes
serveuse vous avez combien d'enfants
vous êtes vous occupez de lui toute
seule toute seule aujourd'hui vous êtes
serveuse vous travaillez combien
d'heures par jour
non mais à peu près voilà vous
travaillez minimum 7 heures 7 heures
donc aujourd'hui vous êtes seul avec un
enfant vous êtes seul avec un enfant
vous travaillez elle travaille elle
essaie de faire le maximum et
aujourd'hui vous en sortez pas non je
suis encore chez mes parents voilà donc
parce que vous pouvez pas aujourd'hui
est-ce que je peux pas me payer un
appartement voilà parce que même de la
location moi je suis dans la banlieue
parisienne donc je pense que vous devez
faire j'espère en tout cas que vous
savez le prix d'un loyer moyen là-bas
HLM étant donné que j'ai fait ma demande
d'HLM enceinte qu'on m'a donné 5 ans
d'attente donc c'est bien une fois qu'il
est à l'école
et donc et donc vous Carla parce que je
crois qu'il y a deux problèmes en fait
je pense que il y a surtout le problème
de la retraite mais c'est pas ça le
problème c'est que si les Français sont
dans la rue aujourd'hui si dans le
Français sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
c'est qu'il y a pas que ça c'est
l'accumulation aujourd'hui Carla je suis
sûr et certain bien sûr que ça compte
pour elle la réforme de la retraite mais
ce qui compte pour elle aujourd'hui
c'est qu'à l'instant T aujourd'hui elle
s'en sort pas et qu'elle se dit
aujourd'hui j'aimerais bien qu'on on
s'occupe de moi et qu'on essaye de de
m'aider et que moi qui travaille tous
les jours je dois m'en sortir bah c'est
ça j'ai 21 ans et je suis chez mes
parents voilà j'ai pas de vie
personnelle j'ai pas de vie privée j'ai
rien parce que je veux Daniel Moreau
elle a 80 ans
ouais j'ai trouvé une convocation
voilà si vous voulez non mais Carla on
en rigole mais je pense que le fond du
problème parce que je vous dis Shannon
je vous jure que quand je vous parlais
de timing tout à l'heure je pense que
c'est vraiment et excusez-moi un Jordan
vous y connaissez mieux que moi et vous
aussi Chanel mais je pense vraiment pour
avoir parlé énormément de français je
pense aussi vraiment que c'est le gros
problème c'est à dire que là il n'aille
pas besoin de ça en plus est-ce que
c'est ça car là en plus pour mon cas à
moi qui est le cas de beaucoup c'est que
j'ai pas un mauvais salaire mais c'est
ça je sais pas un mauvais salaire
exactement
le loyer la voiture l'assurance les
courses si vous avez ne serait-ce que
même l'essence la crèche voilà
exactement ou alors un truc tout bête
mais même inscrire votre fils à la
natation pour qu'il fasse au moins une
activité il sera scolaire mais ça vous
coûte excusez-moi mais une blinde mais
il a que deux ans ce que vous me dites
je le mesure je le comprends encore une
fois je suis élu à Rosny-sous-Bois en
Seine-Saint-Denis vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que c'est un des départements les
plus pauvres de France métropolitaine
quand je vais sur le terrain tous les
weekends et que je vais à la rencontre
des habitants de ma ville et du
département je sillonne le département
la Seine-Saint-Denis je me rends compte
je le vous arrivez à être un problème il
y a un problème de pouvoir d'achat ou le
mesure vous savez vous vous me parliez
car là et c'est un témoignage qui touche
et qui touche et je crois qu'on peut
tous s'identifier
quand on fait de la politique c'est pour
résoudre les problèmes des gens et c'est
pour faire prendre un minimum d'empathie
mais vous oui
c'est que justement on agit car là le
trimestre anti-inflation est-ce que vous
avez entendu parler de ce trimestre
anti-inflation
le trimestre entier qui vient de
démarrer il y a quelques jours c'est
quoi ça
Bruno Le Maire qui est ministre de
l'économie et des finances
ça ministre délégués laissez-moi finir
monsieur Bardella avec Olivia Grégoire
qui est sa ministre délégué en charge
des petites et des moyens des
entreprises a fait le tour des grands
distributeurs mais le seul la seule
réforme que j'ai entendu moi c'est qu'il
a mis un col roulé qui a donc tu as donc
été faire le tour des opérateurs de la
grande distribution pour négocier
justement une réduction de marge et un
effort laissez-moi finir monsieur
Bardella qui a donc négocié justement
qui est une réduction sur certains prix
du quotidien on fait ce qu'on peut car
là soyez
convaincuserez complètement
une question vous m'avez dit ce que je
m'inquiète pour la retraite de mon fils
je m'inquiète pour la retraite de mon
fils mais avant le match était pour ça
t'inquiète déjà pour savoir s'il va
manger s'il va avoir faim toute sa vie
[Applaudissements]
je vous jure que c'est vrai qu'en une
phrase elle a résumé je pense 95% des
Français elle pense à ce qu'elle va
manger demain
quelque chose Monsieur J'ai perdu mon
père il y a 3 ans ma mère se retrouve
seule veuve avec elle est commerçante et
immigré sur le sol français elle est
commerçante et elle se retrouve tous les
matins elle est ouvrir son magasin où
elle vend des costumes de Paris
mais elle tient et elle reconnaît en
tant que combattante commerciale pour
protéger le pouvoir d'achat de nos
concitoyens et nos entreprises avec le
quoi qu'il encouragent avec le fond de
solidarité avec des hommes c'est le
gouvernement d'Emmanuel Macron je peux
tout entendre je peux tout entendre je
peux entendre vos difficultés mais
cracher sur la politique a été celle de
notre gouvernement pendant toutes ces
années pendant le dernier quinquennat
d'Emmanuel Macron avec une banque de
chômage on est désormais à moins de 3
millions de chômeurs sur le sol français
1,2 millions d'emplois qui étaient créés
nous n'avons jamais été aussi
vous pouvez pas rentrer là-dedans mais
non mais
sur le sujet le sujet c'est qu'en fait
on a le sentiment qu'on a à la tête du
pays des gens qui n'aiment pas les
Français et que en réalité les gens se
disent mais est-ce que un jour on va
avoir à la tête de l'état des gens qui
nous aiment qui nous respectent qui nous
considèrent parce que quand vous avez un
Français sur deux qui est à 10 euros
près quand il fait ses courses quand
vous avez des gens aujourd'hui qui dans
les campagnes limitent leurs
déplacements parce que le carburant est
trop cher pourquoi parce qu'il y a 60%
de taxes sur l'essence que vous refusez
de baisser notamment la TVA sur les
carburants sur l'énergie et bien les
gens se disent mais quand vous arrivez
en face de en leur disant on a
démagogique
mais les gens ont parce qu'en réalité ce
panier anti-inflation c'est rien c'est
du vent vous avez délégué la question du
pouvoir d'achat au
professionnel de l'agroalimentaire le
taux de marge de l'agroalimentaire il
est passé en un an de 30 à 45%
l'agroalimentaire fait des super profits
de dingue et vous refusez les taxer
quand vous achetez je dis aux gens quand
vous achetez un bidon de lessive arrière
à 12 euros vous avez 3 euros qui partent
immédiatement dans les supers profits et
qui vont engraisser les actionnaires ce
sont des super profits indus il faudra
les taxer plutôt que de taxer toujours
les mêmes mais il y a beaucoup de gens
et notamment les classes populaires les
classes moyennes qui bossent qui ont le
sentiment qu'on tape toujours sur eux
que c'est toujours à eux qu'on demande
des comptes et que ce sont toujours eux
qui doivent payer pour le reste de la
société
mais il y a des propositions on verra ça
on est pas dans un débat politique là
s'il vous plaît juste
qui était pour la réforme des retraites
dans tous les autres pays européens en
France bah partout en fait en Italie
entre en Italie on prend la retraite
beaucoup plus tard il me semble et en
Allemagne c'est vrai vous avez raison et
en Allemagne il y a deux fois plus de
retraités pauvres voilà et en Suède par
exemple là il y a un mois le directeur
général de la sécurité sociale en Suède
qui a mis en place la réforme des
retraites à 65 ans en Suède il a fait
une interview à BFM TV et il dit
Emmanuel Macron ne fait pas ça ne faites
pas cette réforme on l'a fait en Suède
ça a amené à la baisse des pensions de
retraite pour 70% des femmes et 90% des
hommes pourquoi pour une raison très
simple c'est que l'espérance de vie en
bonne santé elle stagne donnant notre
pays et que quand on repousse l'âge de
départ à la retraite bah il y a des gens
qui peuvent pas tuer à la tâche et qui
donc mécaniquement vont partir plus tôt
et donc vont partir avec une décote et
au fond c'est ça l'objectif de cette
réforme Cyril c'est d'aller faire des
économies sur les pensions de retraite
l'Allemagne c'est bien 67 ans
en Italie financer le déficit du système
des retraites mais une proposition
d'abord Macron est arrivé premier
c'était un moyen les élections
présidentielles Marine Le Pen était 2e
Mélenchon était 3e donc vous étiez quand
même derrière Macron il y a une élection
entre temps oui après il y a une
élection législative il n'a pas eu la
majorité non mais il a il a une quand
même une meilleure
majorité pour mettre en place son projet
d'un point de vue psychanalytique
pourquoi si la réforme est si
catastrophique que ça pourquoi quand
même il va absolument la faire c'est à
dire que moi mais pourquoi c'est ça
alors attendez attendez il répond mais
pourquoi en fait aussi un populaire
aussi dépensé il a rien à il a rien à
gagner en fait je peux rien faire je
pense que c'est une affaire d'ego et je
pense que tout un gouvernement comme ça
qui est derrière lui en ego complètement
aveuglé débile Emmanuel Macron a un ego
surdimensionné donc que pour une
histoire mais étant donné que c'est la
seule mesure la seule qui l'a promis
dans son projet présentiel qui était de
repousser l'âge de départ à la retraite
il veut aller au bout et il veut aller
au bout pour une raison très simple
c'est qu'il se fout complètement des
gens et quand les gilets jaunes arrivent
sur la scène politique en 2018 il ne
connaît pas ces gens c'est des gens qui
gagnent 1200 euros et qui lui disent
mais en fait j'arrive plus à mettre de
l'essence dans ma voiture il ne les a
jamais rencontrés et je ne lui en veux
pas d'avoir eu un parcours universitaire
brillant d'avoir été un banquier
brillant je ne lui en veux pas mais je
dis juste qu'il y a des réalités
concrètes de la vie des gens qui lui
échappent et vous vous souvenez
d'ailleurs qu'en 2019 il avait dit mais
jamais je ne repousserai là je départ à
la retraite il le dit en 2019 il dit
pourquoi il dit mais parce que
aujourd'hui vous ne pouvez pas arriver
aujourd'hui à des gens qui a 62 ans
n'arrive plus à aller au bout de leur
année parce qu'ils sont usés fatigués
par le travail pourquoi est-ce qu'il a
changé d'avis en quelques mois et il y a
aussi une autre raison c'est que c'est
une exigence de la Commission européenne
et que je voulais juste
interview de Clément Beaune en septembre
2020 dans Ouest-France Clément bonne il
est ministre des Transports il était à
l'époque en charge des affaires
européennes il dit dans westfrance à un
de vos confrères un journaliste qui dit
mais quelles vont être les contreparties
du plan de relance et de l'argent que
donne l'Europe à la France pour la
relance covid et Clément bon il dit
l'une des contreparties de la Commission
européenne que nous mettre en œuvre
c'est la réforme des retraites donc
voilà elle est là la réalité et je peux
vous dire que s'il va au bout c'est
parce qu'il a la Commission européenne
qui le presse d'aller au bout et qui
depuis 10 ans dans toutes les
réclamations qu'elle fait chaque année à
la France qu'elle formule à l'état
français il y a la réforme des retraites
Shannon je suis Shannon est-ce que vous
vous étiez pour cette réforme des
retraites vraiment merci parce que vous
êtes obligé de suivre le mouvement moi
je ne suis je ne suis aucun mouvement si
je viens ce soir ici c'est en tant que
je suis né à Bagnolet en
Seine-Saint-Denis en tant que citoyenne
appelle ce que appeler ça comme vous
voulez mais je suis intimement
convaincue du bien fondé de cette
réforme parce que quand on regarde les
chiffres la fin les chiffres monsieur
Bardella et Marine Le Pen le
rassemblement national dans son ensemble
n'aime pas les chiffres
vous vous êtes à l'aise avec les
chiffres quand il s'agit de faire des
emprunts auprès des banques russes et
hongroises pour financer des campagnes
présidentielles moi ce que je vais vous
dire Monsieur Bardella c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on a un système des
retraites qui est déficitaire que si
nous continuons comme ça nous allons
avoir un système de retraite qui sera
déficitaire de plus de 150 milliards
d'euros au sein des 10 prochaines années
et que si on continue comme ça
malheureusement
monsieur terminer sur ce point-ci on ne
pourra pas malheureusement verser de
pensions à nos retraités à nos jeunes
pourquoi vous faites dans les prochaines
années mais parce que
on nous a dit ça moi je m'en rappelle et
je suis pas il nous disait ça il y a 20
ans il disait en 2023 vous allez voir ça
va être l'Apocalypse non mais c'est vrai
c'est ce qu'on nous disait en 2003 on
disait en 2023 ça va être l'Apocalypse
ça va être ça va être un truc de fou
vous allez voir plus personne ne pourra
avoir de retraite etc pourquoi c'est pas
arrivé j'ai une question à vous j'ai une
question à vous poser à vous
individuellement et à nous tous sur le
plateau collectivement vous qui êtes ici
également est-ce qu'on prendrait le
risque de d'actionner un 49-3 une
réforme scientopulaire est-ce qu'on se
permettrait de prendre un risque tel si
cette réforme n'était pas nécessaire
vous êtes quoi vous êtes déjà
génial c'est que si en fait les gens
allaient bien il y avait plus de chômage
qu'ils avaient réglé le déficit 600
milliards de dettes en 5 ans les
services publics parce qu'on peut être
plus en plus d'impôts mais il y a de
moins en moins de service public on se
dirait bon ces mecs là sont des cadors
et à ce moment-là ok on veut bien les
croire mais c'est pas le cas mais c'est
facile
sont bêtes en fait
les gens ne comprennent pas mais
monsieur Bardella les Français ne sont
pas dupe et nous ne sommes bien
conscients des difficultés qui sont ceux
de nos concitoyens mais on doit faire
preuve de responsabilité et de courage
ce même courage monsieur Bardella que
vous n'avez pas en proposant votre
mutisme était assourdissant avouez
monsieur Bardella que votre mutisme
était assourdissant au sein de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale
européen donc c'est sûr vous n'avez pas
beaucoup entendu à l'Assemblée nationale
quelles ont été vos propositions au sein
de l'hémicycle quand il s'agissait de
débattre autour de cette forme
je voudrais savoir
on a des on a des citoyens ici autour de
la table pour est-ce que pourquoi vous
êtes contre cette réforme vous je
voudrais savoir pourquoi vous êtes
contre alors moi c'est une question de
timing on ne peut pas c'est ce que j'ai
dit tout à l'heure
on ne peut pas pour moi mais c'est le
timing non je suis contente parce que le
timing n'est pas bon et je ne sais pas
quand le timing sera bon pour moi les
retraites n'étaient pas le sujet les
sujets c'est la vie quotidienne des gens
c'est ça et moi j'ai une question à vous
poser vous parler de courage est-ce que
ça me concerne pas à l'aveuglement parce
que vous avez contre vous l'hémicycle
tous les partis politiques les syndicats
tous les Français dans la rue qui
s'embrassent on regrette les
débordements mais les gens manifestent
c'est justement ce que disait Géraldine
pourquoi il le ferait madame pourquoi
vous avez voulu imposer ça est-ce que
vous n'avez pas commis une immense
erreur stratégique et est-ce que vous ne
la regrettez pas là ce soir sur le
plateau mais parce qu'ils sont
déconnectés ils sont déconnectés vous
êtes président Macron est déconnecté je
suis désolé
je crois que vous vous méprenez parce
que quand vous regardez aujourd'hui les
les les comment dire les les passer
professionnels si je puis dire des
députés notre groupe Renaissance à
l'assemblée de la rue je vous parle de
la rue son grand nombre madame viennent
de la société civile et sont justement
tous les week-ends
on assume le gouvernement assume sa
responsabilité a pris sa responsabilité
et c'est ça que d'être responsabilités
et quels que d'être à la tête que d'un
pays comme la France nous verrons ce
qu'il adiendra à l'ici l'état du pays ce
soir Madame mais je le regrette mais je
le regrette
c'est une question à vous poser on
entend beaucoup parler de motion de
censure l'opposition énorme dont il
compte se servir c'est la motion de
censure j'aimerais savoir ce que ça veut
dire ce que c'est et ce que ça pourrait
impliquer pour les Français ça va
vraiment parce que moi je sais quoi
49-3 le gouvernement fait passer le
texte en engageant sa responsabilité je
fais de la pédagogie pour tout le monde
comprenne
d'office sauf sauf si une motion de
censure c'est-à-dire la censure du
gouvernement est votée par la moitié de
l'Assemblée nationale c'est-à-dire que
si la moitié des députés s'accordent sur
une motion de censure 1 le texte ne
passe pas c'est-à-dire si l'opposition
se rassemble le texte ne passe pas et de
le gouvernement est contraintes
démissionner alors moi je vais vous dire
est-ce que c'est possible ça je pense
que c'est possible et je vais vous dire
quelque chose je pense que l'ensemble
des mouvements d'opposition doivent
faire passer l'intérêt des Français
l'intérêt de la France l'intérêt de du
modèle social des Français avant
l'intérêt des partis politiques je sais
qu'il y a beaucoup de gens au
républicains à droite qui sont en train
d'hésiter aujourd'hui et moi j'ai envie
de dire à ces députés là courageux qui
hésite chez LR d'avoir le courage de
résister aux pressions et de résister à
la macronie et je veux leur dire qu'en
cas de dissolution de l'Assemblée
nationale le rassemblement national ne
présentera pas de candidats dans les
circonscriptions ou les députés des
républicains votre est avec nous la
motion de censure
des Français qui ne veulent pas de cette
réforme est-ce que une fois une fois on
peut mettre de côté les étiquettes
politiques est-ce que une fois on peut
mettre de côté l'intérêt de nos parties
l'intérêt de notre boutique et se mettre
autour de la table pour l'intérêt
mais on voit bien cette brèche elle est
fondamentale c'est un choix de société
est-ce que c'est possible ça mais moi de
toute façon je n'ai pas à dire
aujourd'hui ce vendredi soir sur votre
parce qu'il y a beaucoup de gens qui
disent que c'est possible dès lundi non
mais on peut on peut faire tous les
calculs par ici on peut prendre une
feuille moi je n'irai pas sur ce terrain
là
c'est impossible de le dire vous savez
qu'il y a quelques jours
disaient juste pour qu'on comprenne tous
les ministres disaient il y aura pas de
49-3 parce qu'on aura la majorité or
quelques heures avant le vote ils se
sont aperçus qu'il n'avaient pas de
majorité donc l'Assemblée nationale est
opposé à cette réforme c'est pour ça que
je dis qu'il faut arrêter le sectarisme
un peu à la nupette qui pousse à la
bêtise si pour une fois on se met autour
de la table dans l'intérêt des Français
cette réforme de passe pas mais genre le
gouvernement vous savez qu'il manque 30
voix des républicains et là je vais leur
dire venez avec nous on vote tous
ensemble c'est exactement donc j'ai
au groupe des Républicains pour qu'il
fasse preuve de cohérence
il y a quand même un esprit de
responsabilité avoir derrière tout ça
monsieur Bardella et vous le savez mieux
que moi aujourd'hui les républicains et
comme vous j'en appelle ici à la
responsabilité des élus du groupe
républicain pendant la campagne des
présidentielles avec Valérie Pécresse
notamment ils ont défendu justement une
réforme d'alertes avec un âge légal à 65
ans
avec des heures et des heures de débat
au sein de l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée on
a révisé cette question
le révisant de 65 à 64 ans faisant
preuve d'un minimum de bon sens et de
cohérence et ici si les députés les
républicains veulent pouvoir regarder
leurs élus droit dans les yeux je les
invite bien évidemment à ne pas voter
cette motion de censure et encore une
fois je crois si vous me permettez de
terminer qu'on assiste ici un grand
moment de vérité sur votre plateau et je
suis ravie de le voir puisque monsieur
Bardella nous dit clairement qu'il n'a
aucune ligne politique et qu'il est
prête à s'allier avec l'extrême gauche
pour justement voter cette motion de
censure faites preuve faites preuve
justement monsieur barder la minimum
d'honnêteté intellectuel envers vos
électeurs en de vous alliant pas à
l'extrême gauche et en votant cette
notion de censure je vous parle de LR
alors juste
revenir sur un truc parce que vous
parlez que vous passez des heures et des
heures à des heures à pondre des trucs
qui finalement font chier tout le monde
sauf que la question oui
c'est toujours je suis la fille de ma
mère je suis toujours polie mais bref
donc en fait lorsque vous êtes en train
de me vendre c'est que je vais
travailler jusqu'à 63 ans parce que j'ai
de la chance j'ai commencé à 20 ans donc
normalement je crois que c'est 63 si on
n'a pas encore changé le truc bien
évidemment je suis serveuse donc à 63
ans je vais encore me taper les 26
services en haut en bas en haut en bas
avec mon plateau dans les mains ça sera
super ça va être génial ça sera un petit
peu moins vendeur mais c'est pas grave
et en plus de ça je vais avoir une paye
de merde parce que je vais avoir du coup
bah la bouche qui va me coûter plus cher
l'essence c'est pas fini la vie je vous
en parle même pas donc en fait vous
voulez que je parte à 63 ans mais j'ai
une vie de merde jusqu'à 63 ans vous
savez que parce qu'en fait reculer la
retraite et me promettre et me promettre
les monts et merveilles comme quoi
j'aurais pas galéré
ok je veux bien aller jusqu'à 63 ans
alors si je sais que pendant ces 63
années là j'ai pour aller boire un verre
avec une copine sans me poser la
question de si ça va perturbé tout mon
frigo à la fin du mois et de pouvoir
enfin me barrer de chez mes parents même
si je les aime de tout mon cœur voyez en
fait on les embrasse je pense sauf que
là en fait vous me promettez que des
choses ce que je vois mais ce que je
vous dis NON je l'espère sauf que c'est
que je vous promets ce que je vous
promets faire des études mais une fois
que vous avez un bac vous pouvez pas
mais bon ça c'est un autre débat mais
bon c'est aussi vous mais c'est pas
grave c'est un autre sujet
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui parce que c'est la
grande question que tout le monde se
pose il est 21h09 son nom en direct
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui dès lundi on peut
avoir un gouvernement qui sauterait
est-ce que c'est possible ou est-ce que
c'est de l'ordre de l'utopie si la
motion de censure est à côté c'est la
conséquence le Gouvernement aujourd'hui
les rép quelqu'un ils iront pas contre
le alors
très simple aux Français je leur dis
n'ayez pas peur il n'y a pas de fatalité
si le gouvernement ça veut dire qu'il
devait ne pas tomber on doit repartir
ils sont pas sûrs
qui ont été élu pas de prendre le risque
de se dire on va peut-être sauter
derrière c'est pour ça qu'il leur promet
de la présenter
par ailleurs ce qui a dit que
effectivement il ne voterait pas la
motion censure mais 50 secondes après il
y avait quelques dissidents déjà qui
commençait à dire que peut-être
juste pour que les gens comprennent bien
en fait quand vous regardez tous les
sondages chez LR la moitié des électeurs
de LR bon il en reste plus beaucoup mais
la moitié des électeurs de LR est
partagé entre pour la réforme contre la
réforme et il y a une majorité dans le
dernier sondage je crois que c'est
Harris des lecteur des républicains 53%,
je crois que c'est à risque qui souhaite
que les députés LR votent la motion de
censure parce que le problème de LR
c'est qu'en fait il y a une partie des
gens de LR notamment Ciotti Marley qui
rêve d'être ministre de Macron et donc
ils veulent être plus que Macron est
donc qui donne tous les gages il se
Macron vous êtes génial on va voter la
réforme faux réformer il faut du courage
etc sauf qu'il y a beaucoup d'électeurs
de LR qui sont des électeurs un peu
perdus et qui ne veulent pas de cette
réforme et qui se disent en tout cas
c'est le mauvais timing parce qu'il y a
beaucoup de députés derrière
la réalité
c'est possible ou pas moi vous êtes
confiante moi je suis plutôt confiante
mais après encore une fois je ne suis
pas dans les chiffres et je pense qu'il
y a des négociations
moi la question qui se pose derrière
tout ça la question qui se pose derrière
tout ça c'est de pouvoir faire en sorte
de rétablir un petit peu de sérénité
dans la rue est-ce que vous avez vu les
scènes auxquelles on assiste
va revenir les scènes de Shadows parce
que
on peut pas on peut pas on peut c'est
une admissible c'est celle de les scènes
de chaos mais on peut pas empêcher les
gens d'aller dans la rue parce qu'ils
sont pas d'accord avec eux mais en fait
ça fait avancer le débat non mais non
non
des gens de manifester déjà
si vous prenez tout ce qu'ils ont ou en
tout cas ce qui pourrait avoir et vous
vous étonnez qui finissent par faire des
trucs un peu bête cette réforme des
retraites cette réforme des retraites
justement ce que oui ici on ne comprend
pas c'est que c'est justement l'occasion
de revoir de fond en comble un système
de retraite par répartition qui est un
bien précieux
ils voient pas la retraite et leur
système de répartition ils en ont rien à
Carrera on va pas manger demain ma fille
elle va pas manger demain je vais pas
avoir de travail mais ils en ont rien à
carrer de ça et je pense que l'urgence
elle est plus là qui allait faire les
retraites il y avait une solution
c'était le référendum nous on avait
proposé la motion de censure de la rue
permettrait pour nous du quotidien des
Français avant de s'occuper de du
quotidien des Français dans 40 ans le
retrait du texte ou le référendum
pourquoi on consulte jamais les Français
par effet un homme nous on a défendu le
référendum ça fait 18 ans que les
Français ont pas été construits sur un
truc comme ça j'en ai juste mais les
Français ont été consultés lors des
élections présidentielles
majorité excusez-moi
je crois qu'aujourd'hui je sais que ça
ne vous fait pas plaisir et que c'est
pas une réalité qui est agréable à vivre
au quotidien mais aujourd'hui on a un
président de la République qui est
Emmanuel Macron qui a été élu
légitimement dans la chambre